a ban on imports of russian coal comes
into effect in europe today eu countries
agreed on the embargo earlier this year
as part of sanctions over russia's
invasion of ukraine many european
countries have relied on russia to
supply energy in the form of coal much
of that coal was imported to europe
through the port of rotterdam in the
netherlands
let's cross over to rotterdam now where
our reporter barbara basil is standing
by
barbara the countries were rushing to
stock up on russian coal before the
embargo came into effect what's the
situation now
now we're in the harbor of rotterdam at
the cave where coal is unloaded you can
see one of those river barges that the
coal is put onto
right in the back here and further in
the back there are those big piles of
coal this is lignite so it doesn't
really look black there is a sort of
whitish residue on it but it this is the
stuff that really
goes into power plants that is mostly
used for electricity and the harbor of
rotterdam as of today declares no more
russian coal not a bucketful anywhere
here so they started fading it out there
there was a peak in in may about when
everyone was as you said stocking up on
coal trying to get in as much as
possible quickly but now it has gone
down to zero all the freighters that
used to be way out of sight of the
harbor
have been unloaded over the last two
three months and now it's all gone no
more will be coming in because european
countries say and of course the rob the
hub of rotterdam needs to enforce that
this is the end the embargo starts as of
today and they have to find coal in
different from different suppliers
now this uh embargo is coming into
effect barbara as europe is facing an
energy crisis could this embargo result
in a shortage of coal in europe this
winter leading to power cuts
yes indeed it's a possibility because
there are several factors that are
working together here that are
negative for the supply of
energy to europe
it's not only the coal they are trying
to replace the coal from south africa
even from ecuador from colombia that's
what the harbor told us so it all comes
through the sewers canal now instead of
from the northern russian harbors
but
even if they can sort of get the
quantities the problem also is the price
the price of the coal has tripled since
last year and the transport has become
incredibly difficult because the rhine
the river rhine which is the main
conduit to to transport the coal into
europe is drying up and so the river
barges like the one we see here in the
back it can can't really be loaded very
much anymore only a third of their cargo
and so a lot of barges have to go which
again increases the price and it might
be difficult for up to the winter to get
enough coal in to supply the power
plants and of course
the steel industry that uses coal
now not all eu countries are exposed to
this uh to the to this embargo quite as
much in terms of their loss of coal
supplies which countries are most going
to be most affected by this uh coal
embargo barbara
yeah again it was germany as was the gas
germany imported
14 million tons of russian coal
a year even a year ago and about half of
their imports came from russia so they
were extremely reliant now they have of
course started since the beginning of
the war they have started to replace
this coal from on the sides but as i
said it's a question of the price it's
becoming very it used to be a cheap fuel
it's becoming very expensive now and
they do have to find other places the
netherlands even where we are now they
imported russian coal poland which has
its own mines they had to step up mining
on uh in poland within poland to
increase production there they were
quite reliant and italy so these were
the main import countries and they all
really have to
find new suppliers and they really have
to sort of step up imports in order to
make it through the coming winters
barbara thank you very much our reporter
barbara basil there in rotterdam